if we ask ourselves what reasons do we
have to believe in a soul we might start
by asking these do we have to believe
post-modernism is an eclectic
orientation to the past in a certain
sense it's a return
in many ways the American Revolution was
it just a war the war was actually only
a minor part of the American Revolution
the Romans structured a man-made
worldwide Empire out of architectural
forms and exerted a lasting influence on
the architecture and the architects of
post-classical time great literature
poetry painting music they show what
human beings invented the capacity of
the human spirit I think if you come up
with good true Christian theological
readings of the New Testament and you
can come up with very decent historical
reading to the New Testament they just
always won't be the same kind of leader
this means that not only that the Tree
of Life connect you to all the living
things on the planet but the origin of
life connects you to the entire universe
that's a big boy but reading these
novels is not just reading about those
things it's also going to be the process
of watching an artistic form unfold the
characteristic comment on making a real
discovery is not Eureka it's hump that's
funny
you